welcome back to law and crime daily we
move now to El Paso County Colorado
where Leticia Stout is on trial for the
murder of her stepson three years ago
this week newly released phone calls
give us an inside look into the
defendant's behavior prior to her arrest
eleven-year-old Gannon Stout was
reported missing in January of 2020.
seven weeks later her remain his remains
were found stuffed in a suitcase under a
Florida highway the defendant told
authorities that Gannon went to a
friend's house and never came back but
couldn't give any more details she was
arrested and charged with his murder two
weeks before gannon's remains were found
investigators found blood in the child's
bedroom and the defendant's SUV stalk is
pleading Not Guilty by reason of
insanity this week phone calls are
played to the jury between the defendant
and gannon's father Al stouk the FBI and
Coach gannon's father through the
secretly recorded conversations taking
place after Gannon went missing the
defendant changed her story several
times and one of those stories included
Gannon falling off his bike and being
abducted by a stranger take a listen
I didn't ask you for any kind of
immunity because I committed some kind
of archives
I just know there was an accident not
like it was someone was trying to help
me
and then I didn't know where you went
from there one of them were worried the
most about is the freaking head wound
because what was it how bad was he
bleeding
it's pretty bad it was pretty bad
like like it was it was tell me bad it's
bad like blood's dripping down his face
or bad like he's laying there and
there's a puddle or what oh my dripping
on his face
well did you did you do anything to wrap
around his head or anything
blood on them
you're include the clothes you had on
yeah okay and did this guy did he have a
phone
he said he would run back to his house
and they would call 9-1-1 okay
so he took it into his house is what he
told you right
and and you you
did you stay where you were did you
follow him or what
Dave
the composer of that man to make that
phone call Terry the defendant changed
her story multiple times that indicates
some sort of a trauma-based memory loss
or maybe a cover-up to you well I
definitely think that she changed her
story because it was consciousness of
guilt she knew she was guilty I mean
first she said he went to a friend's
house then she said he ran away then she
said it was an accident then she said
someone named Quincy Brown took him and
then she said she was raped I mean there
were so many stories it's very hard to
keep up and you're right the father was
very good very patient trying to get
that information out of her but I
definitely think the jury hearing what
is going on on that phone listening to
her voice and seeing how many times
she's changing her story they're going
to come back and think you must have
done this you certainly are not mentally
ill because you are able to think about
how you can change your story I mean
Bernard Terry has a good point there
she's pleading Not Guilty by reason of
Insanity would someone not aware of
their actions at the time of the crime
ask from the police
exactly I think it's going to be very
difficult for the defense to actually
Prevail that she suffered from some kind
of mental condition that prevented her
from knowing the difference between
right and wrong because those same acts
as Terry mentioned that were
consciousness of guilt were actually
also showing her mindset her thinking
her thinking as who she knew what she
did what she was wrong so that's why she
had to lie about it but also you got to
look at the 9-1-1 call you have to look
at that they have the truck leaving and
coming back you got to look at also her
actions that she drove across the
country to go bury this child to keep
him away from Colorado so he wouldn't be
found and those actions all show you
that she knew what she did was wrong and
was trying to get away with it yeah on
her defense the insanity of Defense
applies at the time of the murder but
you've really got to thread the needle
with all the facts you two brought up
well we'll continue to follow here on
Law and crime but when we come back
hundreds of undercover police officers
are following lawsuits after their
identities were publicly released online
we're breaking down why by the city of
Los Angeles could be in some serious
legal trouble
[Music]
we finished Today's Show in Los Angeles
where more than 300 undercover police
officers have sued both the city and the
police department after their personal
identities were released without
permission online last month a watchdog
group called stop lapd's spying
Coalition posted nearly 10 000 officers
information and photographs to a
searchable online database this followed
a public records request made by a
reporter for the news Outlet knock La
the officers claimed they had no advance
notice before their information was
published to the database called watch
the Watchers this giant lawsuit was
filed just a week after the LAPD Union
announced they were suing another
website killercop.com for allegedly
putting bounties on officers heads after
a different info leak while public
records requests must be adhered to
under California law exemptions are
often made for safety or investigative
reasons when it comes to undercut for
officers the lawsuits are seeking an
unspecified amount of damages on
negligence claims after the plaintiffs
say they lost their ability to work
undercover or work as police officers
altogether
what are how would the plaintiffs be
able to prove there are exemptions or
exceptions sorry for them when it comes
to public records requests
this is a huge problem Brian because you
got to think this is an important issue
because these officers are working in
the undercover capacity they can no
longer work if their identification
especially their photograph is known to
the public they cannot do their job and
aside from not being able to do their
job their safety is at risk so I think
this has to be carved out as an
exception let's not forget that in New
Jersey just a few years ago remember the
judge whose son was killed as a result
of her information being online and this
person that was demented going to her
house and then ended up shooting her son
so I think something has to be carved
out but the question would be who will
monitor this to make sure that these
websites comply with it yeah I don't
think I'm being too hyperbolic but I
imagine a drug deal going down with an
undercover officer and someone just in
the background being like
is that is that you and then all hell
breaking loose but Terry from a civil
perspective do you think the city is
liable here well listen the fact that
these addresses were given out they
should have known better particularly
because of what we're saying that the
officers lives are at risk here and I do
think that the officers themselves can
say look you owed me a duty of
protection and you failed to do that and
under the California tort act they can
sue you have to give notice that you're
going to sue and they could say look you
endangered me my life is in danger my
family is in danger and this is why we
are suing and I definitely think that
they could have some ramifications here
they could have emotional distress and
they could have negligence suit here and
so no doubt about it I think you could
see some civil actions all around all
across the board but even by the police
officers whose lives I think are in
danger here because their names have
been revealed yeah hey watch the
Watchers but make sure that they're safe
while doing it Bernard Terry thank you
and thank you for joining us here on Law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign